This is Dalton plus Michael. Today we're
going to talk about is startup funding
fair.
So I'll set this up. Instead of working
on your company, you're browsing Twitter
because that's what all good founders
do. And you see company has
just raised a $10 million round from A6Z
and you checked out their product last
week and you're like that product sucks.
And you see all these people being like,
"Oh my god, this company's so great.
They're going to win the space." And you
are starting to think, "Is this all a
joke? I was told this was meritocratic
and d But like these folks suck and
they're raising all the money and they
look like they're cool. What's going
on?"
>> Yeah. [laughter] I mean, look, think
about how many office hours that we do.
>> Yes. where you know there's some other
topic. But when you get right down to
it, what's actually going on is that
someone read a fundraising announcement
and somehow that caused them to go
through a like a total spiral. Like the
founders I'm talking to are spiraling.
>> Yes.
>> Sometimes it's because they're sad.
>> Because um
>> they're Yes. Sometimes it's they're
enraged because how dare this dumb thing
that's so bad that we're better than
them raise money.
>> Yes.
>> Time for revolution.
[laughter]
>> We we need to destroy the venture
capital industry. I'm so mad.
>> Yes.
>> Sometimes it's out of magical thinking
where it's like, hey, I saw someone
raise this money for this voice AI
thing. I think we should do voice AI.
And so they sort of like draw parallels
Yes.
>> to what they're doing. No, I would call
that the pivot. Like we should pivot to
that, right? I think the parallel one is
like a voice AI company raised a billion
dollars. That means we can be worth a
billion dollars, too. Like
>> that means this is working, right? Like
there's a t good news. My startup's
working. Someone raised money.
>> Yes. Yes. These other these other people
these other guys raised money. I'm going
my startup's been great.
>> The number of times I've seen a founder
basically be this is a good space
because there exist n unicorns in the
space. I'm like what does that even what
do these things have to do with each
other?
>> So is it fair? No. [laughter] End of
video. All right. That's not fair.
Sorry.
>> Yeah.
>> And so
>> you're right. [laughter]
It's an injustice.
>> Again, what's funny is that for whatever
reason, startup culture is heavily
centered around
fundraising announcements and reaction
to fundraising announcements,
>> especially early stage.
>> Totally.
>> Yes. And this is like one of the cool
things to talk about with other founders
or with your employees. And it's
>> the goal, right?
>> Sure. They [laughter] um for some reason
this is just like the the latent uh
background radiation of of working in
the space. And what I would say is when
you get over rotated on this stuff, you
are beating yourself.
>> Yes.
>> Yes. you. That is selfdefeating
behavior. Yes.
>> If you let yourself have tons of
emotions as a result of some stranger
raising money from some stranger, right?
Like that's
>> more often than not, it doesn't change
your chance of success at all.
>> No. [laughter]
And then and then you like having
whatever feelings you have about it. No.
>> Again, everyone's feelings are valid,
but you want to learn to quiet that part
of your mind.
>> Yes. And to realize that that doesn't
really affect you too much. No. And
think about how much over the years um
have people on Hacker News or just on
Twitter in general spend
>> Oh god.
>> more time worrying about what stuff you
and I have funded than we worry about.
>> Yes. [laughter] Yeah.
>> I can't believe YC fund duh. Like it's
obviously over. Like
>> And so [laughter] the good news is
we don't care. Like I never once cared
what people on social media would say
when we chose to accept a company.
>> No.
>> And so we weren't looking for the
approval of people on the internet.
>> What if that was the meritocracy is we
we we had to have a vote on the internet
[laughter]
>> about whether we're allowed to fund a
company or not.
>> No. a funding event has become like I
think the only equivalent that I can
imagine in today's day and age is a
strong quarter for a company where the
stock price went up cuz it's like I
think founders truly believe fundraising
events are like valuecreating moments.
What's interesting is like when that
stock price went up that like that is a
value creat like literally everyone's
stock is worth more. They could sell it
right now and make more money than they
could sell it two days ago. A funding
announcement is the announcement of a
illquid bet. And almost every single
fundraising announcement you will read
is an announcement of an illlquid bet
that has a probably less than 50%
likelihood of paying off.
>> Yeah.
>> All the way down to I mean we've joked
about 0% but like all the way down to
seed rounds which like very low expected
of working out.
>> Standard capital my new firm is
operating. We made a number of
investments. Yes,
>> we are going to announce those
investments soon.
>> And so in so far as like if you just
believe all fundraising announcements
are bad, I guess I'm part of the
problem.
>> You are. And you're an investor, right?
So
>> yeah, I suck, right? Um and I'm not do
holding a vote.
>> No, you don't get for who we should
fund. So the reason why it's not fair.
>> Yeah. [laughter]
Holding a vote. Um but the reason
funding is announcements are good.
>> Yes. is I want people
to check out the products
>> of the companies that we invest in
>> and be curious about them.
>> I want potential job candidates
>> to be more interested in taking a job at
the company.
>> Yeah.
>> Basically, it's a good way to remind
people that a company exists. And as you
know from our other videos, friends, the
natural state of startups is no one
cares about your startup. Yes.
>> So, this is a way to get people to like
>> Yes.
>> Look at, hey, look at this thing. it
raised money and you take that attention
and try to transfer it to something
good. Yes.
>> And so in my mind, the healthy way to
view a fundraising announcement is to
take an opportunity to look at the
product
>> to check out the founders
>> to see if there's cool jobs there if
you're in the job market.
>> Have an opinion.
>> To have an opinion and not really have a
lot of emotions about it, you know,
>> like you're just kind of like, oh, cool
opinion.
>> This is a thing like neat. I should go
check out their product. And I have
noticed a lot of founders get good
customers this way.
>> Yes. Like this is why we do all the the
announcements at YC
>> is it drives customers.
>> I think this is a really healthy way of
thinking about it. I think that like
when you see a startup announcement, I
think that like an interesting thought
would be check out the product, check
out some of the case studies, spend 5 10
minutes, make a procon argument in your
head and assign a percentage. And and I
think that as long as you're assigning a
percentage, the startup will will seem
more fair. I think that when you're
assuming that every investor thinks that
every investment has a 100% chance of
success, the bets look stupid. I mean,
people invested in Elon building
rockets. It might have been a high
conviction bet, but like no one could
basically say that was like a high
percentage likelihood to work out. Look,
this was literally in my in my Twitter
exions today.
>> Yeah.
>> So, I founded a company called Whatnot
in Winter 20.
>> Yep.
>> And it just announced it's a decacorn.
They just raised money at 11 billion
valuation. Okay. Why why is that cool?
It's like, hey, you
>> check that out and you know, if you know
someone that wants a job, if you know
someone wants a job, they're hiring. You
know, so that's there's actually
pro-social reasons to to talk about
that. But what's funny is a lot of the
the comments were people being like, I
would never invest in this. How did YC
pick this? Why would this Pokemon
trading card site? Like there's people
being like, I don't like cool that this
is worth so much. Like how on earth
>> did you see it?
>> Did they decide to fund this thing?
>> Yeah.
>> Cuz in the moment, can you imagine what
the like
>> how it was perceived? Oh, Pokemon
>> uh Funko Pop Yeah.
>> trading website raises venture capital.
>> It was a low percentage bet.
>> Well, well, and it would be like
infuriating to people. How dare this
company raise money when my startup is,
which is so much better. Yeah.
>> They're funding this crap. Yeah. Well,
this is how again, this is an
instructive moment. This is why I'm
bringing him up. Well, that worked.
>> Yeah,
>> that bet worked out and created a lot of
jobs and there's a lot of sellers on
whatnot. And so, if you look at the
economic impact of that bet, it was
really good.
>> Yep. Yep. Someone should have made it.
>> Yeah.
>> Well, and and I also think you make a
good point, which is that like you might
think you can tell the future when
you're reading a Twitter funding
announcement.
>> Yep.
>> And you might think if you tried a
product, you know, whether it can be
good or not in the future, but like you
might be wrong. You might be wrong. I'll
say this is the last version of this
that always frustrated me which is um
this happened in my company, this
happened with other founders that I've
advised where like you see somebody fund
raise and then you say if they can
fundraise why can't we fund raise and
you know none of the supporting facts or
materials. Like we saw this in one
situation. Some company we're competing
against raised a whole bunch of money
and we were just like we've pitched
these people like they know us like we
have more traffic like what's going on?
It's crazy. Years later I found out that
that founder made the firm who invested
in them like a billion dollars.
>> I know you're talking about
>> and it was like well you know like if
someone makes you a billion dollars
you'll do their series A for the next
time, [laughter] right? like how much
money are you handing them back after
they handed you a billion dollars,
right? And it had nothing to do with the
core fundamentals or any like but
reading the announcement, I didn't know
that. And so thinking that announcement
has all the supporting materials that
would actually make you understand
whether this a good investment is that
that's not the purpose of a fundraising
announcement. So that's another reason
why you can maybe classify something as
unfair is like you just don't have the
facts. And then the last one you bring
up which is like when people announce
their fundraising round that means they
raised the money that day right that's
that's how that works right
>> yeah often it happened in the past often
they're sort of
>> hopefully not in the future [laughter]
>> often they're um some creative
accounting for how they're discussing
the amount raised or the valuation like
there's all these like slight of hand
things that happen
>> and again the point is to not worry
about it too much it's not real yes it's
[laughter] just a
It's just well and that's why this is
what I love about it's like it's like a
sports bet, right? It's like soon the
game will be over and like most of the
bats [laughter]
will have made no money and some will
like we'll know the answer soon. Before
it's just a bet. Y
>> don't get all worked up over a bet.
Sometimes founders think the
fundraising game is skewed against them
because they make some simple mistakes
where it's harder to fund them. I think
that like, you know, for two kids who
are CS majors at MIT, the fundraising
game might seem real fun, right? Like it
might seem super fair. Like, how how do
you think about kind of your starting
conditions impacting whether you think
the game is fair? If I'm two MBAs from
the University of Phoenix, this game
might not seem so fair. I think some
folks want to believe that the way
capital is allocated is like super
efficient and that it is like there's
some kind of stock market.
>> Yeah,
>> you can write up a little like report.
It's it's like this like public stocks I
guess technically have price to earnings
ratios and people are trading them
>> technically they're priced accurately
actually you actually as you can see in
the current stock market [laughter]
>> maybe
>> but there's a notional sense that you
can value a late stage company and that
there is some like fair way to do it.
>> Yes.
>> And I think people expect
>> that to scale all the way down Yes. Yes.
>> Startup bets
>> and doesn't
>> Well, if it did work it that way,
>> there'd be people making lots of money
investing that way.
>> Yes.
>> Where are they?
>> Yeah.
>> Where are the value where the value
investors in startups? I'm not trying to
maybe they exist. Like, let me know. Um,
but from what we have seen, that is a
very bad way to invest in startups is to
try to find the stuff with the lowest
valuation, like the highest revenue,
stuff like that. That stuff doesn't
work. and instead it's much more of
an art and it's hard to justify every
decision that other people are making
about this stuff
>> and you're always going to have an
opinions. Maybe this is a weird aside,
but it's almost like looking at who gets
drafted every year in a draft or who who
get you're like why didn't this guy get
signed and you're like why didn't this
team sign this player? Like it's easy to
be on the sidelines. Yeah. And to and to
feel that you have a perfect view of who
did what, but
>> you know, ultimately you're just like a
person on a comment board.
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> And not someone whose job is on the line
to make good decisions, right?
>> I actually, you know, you said fun is I
think start funding is funding is more
fair than I I I ever realized. And I
think one of the driving factors in that
is it's there isn't one big company
doing all of it.
>> Yeah. like there's just there are so
many
>> writers basically [laughter]
there's very little coordination
especially at the seed stage there's no
coordination and so having all of these
>> there's some coordination
>> well like uh it's more likely to raise
money if you're an MIT CS major than not
>> I'm just trying to say if someone says
no
>> it doesn't poison the well there's no
like secret back channel
>> so there's a lot of people yeah there's
a lot of money
>> and they're all operating autonomously
yes that seems pretty fair. And I would
argue that the most basic things they're
looking for tend to be publicized.
>> Yeah.
>> Like YC, we don't hide what we're
looking for in a YC application. And so
that's also pretty fair. I'd also argue
nowadays investors are more accessible
than like they ever were before, right?
You can tweet at people. You can
>> use AI to figure out everyone's email
addresses, right? And so they're
accessible. They compete with each
other. They don't really coordinate with
each other and they generally
communicate what they were looking for.
You know, it's it's interesting because
like if you think about it in a sports
analogy, right? It's so like from that
perspective, I think the basketball
industry is also kind of accessible.
Like it doesn't mean you're going to
become NBA.
>> It's pretty straightforward how you
would get signed to the Warriors.
>> Yes.
>> But that doesn't mean it's easy. No, no,
no. But if you're like the best player
on your high school basketball team and
you're like 68, you know, like Yeah. If
you're seven feet, yeah, like the
industry kind of will find [laughter]
you. So, no, I I I think though, maybe
to wrap up, right, certainly getting
angry and discouraged by fundraising
announcements and and and by thinking
the fundraising environment isn't fair,
like that's not going to help you win.
Yep.
>> Right. Like I think that like you should
trust that if you just put that stuff
aside and focus on things that actually
might help you win, you might find the
fundraising environment more accessible
than you than you thought. Most of the
rounds that we see from most of the good
companies, they're doing something
interesting or they've done something
interesting and investment came as a
result. It wasn't investment just came
before they did anything or they like
they they had agency. You had agency.
That's a great point. All right. Thanks
for the chat. All right. Thanks,
Michael.